today on stick to football we're gonna
run down all the news and notes
surrounding the NFL NFL Draft and free
agency we're gonna give you our dream
quarterback Fitz
a player spotlight is back and then some
draft on draft questions to end this
thing you get again Matt Melo and Connor
you can check us out on Bleacher
Report's youtube page there's a stick to
football playlist or you listen to the
show three times a week wherever you get
your podcast at fellas I'm gonna say it
again please continue to stay home if
you can wash those hands I saw the thing
people in Texas are saying wash your
hands like you just cut jalapenos and
have to change your contacts yeah I
think that's a good plan I never get you
to do it right I mean I could I could
list some different ones out there but
yeah I think just wash your hands you
shouldn't need an excuse to do it like
I'll be the first guy to admit I was not
washing my hands regularly I had no idea
how fast I would go through hand soap
but now that I have it and I'm washing
my hands just do it it's not that bad
although I will let's get weird to start
off the show I thought it was supposed
to wash my hands for two minutes instead
of 20 oh yeah so can you imagine the
amount of time I've been spending
washing my hands like there's pretty
much no skin left on my hands after two
minutes so how long do you brush it
rubbing see I thought they were both two
minutes okay so at least you're doing it
you're overdoing it that's the most
important super-clean Melo has eczema
now you can see it on YouTube all right
speaking of videos they came out to uh
releases a video on his Twitter account
Monday night and I have to tell you guys
it's probably the best video I've seen
since the shutdown my man looks good
running through cone drills throwing the
ball and I loved that he specifically
releases a video where we see him moving
putting pressure on the hip having to
torque having to rotate he looks in
great shape as well I know that was
something we had talked to a lot of
people about hey is he what's he gonna
look like when we get through this is he
gonna be 240 or is he gonna be 200
pounds where is he gonna be in terms of
his conditioning he looks fantastic
I think as good as he's looked since I
became aware of him at least as a
freshman quarterback the video it's
crisp he's showing his footwork as Jodie
and the throw looks good and I know
we've talked about this before a healthy
tool is not that far behind Jobar Oh as
the best quarterback in
this class I mean I think you could even
say he might not be behind I love this
video from - I think the only people
that are gonna hate this video are
Dolphins fans in the Dolphins
organization because they might actually
have to trade some of those first-round
picks now because after this video I
think that he's in play for three I
think teams like the Chargers are gonna
be trying to get up there I think the
Patriots here we're gonna be trying to
get up there and you know that Belichick
can work with his guy Patricia and get
something done so the Dolphins I
wouldn't sit around and wait too long I
think - it looks great I'm trying to get
up to that number three maybe even
number two spot to grab this guy from
the Dolphins yeah this could not have
been released it feels like I had a
better time to kind of set the world on
fire everyone was like oh [ __ ] like we
didn't think he'd be moving like that
already and everybody has the concerns
about the the no tree checks because a
cove at 19 right now and how it would
impact tua and non combine invites but
this is obviously just great news for
tua and I think it raised everyone's
eyebrows because like you said Matt that
might be the most nimble we've seen him
since we watched to a play or at least
that's what it felt like it does almost
seem like maybe this time off has been
good for him you know maybe the ankle is
healthy right not to make everything
about about our guy mahomes but some of
the you know he had the he had the ankle
injury then when he hurts his knee well
he had time to heal the ankle and so
it's like with tua I almost feel the
same way all the bumps and bruises that
he accumulated at Alabama have had time
to heal now because he's had this now
four months five months of not doing
anything but rehabbing the hip so he
does look healthier and I think what's
encouraging about this we've all been
excited about the the you know x-rays
and scans and everything looks good but
we've always prefaced it and said
according to his agent who's leaking it
to reporters this video is not least I'm
Berg's word for it we're seeing it we're
seeing him move and I would not be
surprised I know that some people in
that camp listen to this show hey guys
give us a 10 minute video of him
throwing a movie yeah that's what I was
saying this is a really good clip I do
want to see what that hip looks like for
a little bit longer than the ten seconds
or whatever that video was but I still
think that he's working on getting back
in shape I mean he's just now moving
around a little bit so you're probably
not gonna see a lot but I do think it
gives you a lot of good positive
feelings for the sea
and going forward if you are a team that
is in need of a quarterback without a
doubt I mean it definitely helps and I
know people some people sit there and
say well it's just the video but I
really do think something like that
helps and I'm torn guys I don't know
what Miami's gonna do in terms of
whether they sit there at 5:00 whether
they come up for two of whether the
Chargers come up for two a how team's
view Justin Herbert in comparison it's
who and obviously every all those things
are gonna be tight-lipped and if you do
hear something that evident it's
probably a smoke screen so I think this
is one of the more fascinating battles
for post quarterback one between 2:00
and 3:00 it feels kind of like I mean we
thought Sam Donald was going number one
for a very very long time but then there
was that mix of Baker Rosen and Alan how
they would come off the board and I will
say as far as you like you mentioned
they're like oh like insider news and
they like we're if we hear anything it's
a smoke screen more than ever none of us
are gonna have a [ __ ] clue what's
happening because Scouts aren't in the
building so like the area I guess that
you normally give us information they're
not in the building so like even now
like I've been texting my group of
friends who are general managers they're
even saying things like man we don't
know you know like um you know I'll ask
a question about some obscure guy
there's the wide receiver from Miami
Jeff Thomas I text yesterday we're doing
Draft 400 I text a couple people hey
like do you think he gets drafted there
were a couple gyms that were like we are
not even close to having an opinion on a
guy like that right now so it's still
it's not the house right I went ahead
and let them know he's not draftable but
you know just it's still like you would
expect them to be farther ahead at this
point in time so and and that could vary
team to team but there are a lot of
folks who are they feel like they're
behind the ball now let's move ahead
here Trent Williams Washington Redskins
did not play last year and he releases
on Tuesday morning a statement through
his agent to Adam Schefter and Ian
Rapoport and the rest of that crew that
he was released or traded now it seems
like he's a little upset that Quentin
Dunbar spoke out against the team he got
traded to Seattle for fifth round pick
and here he is and played near and can't
get moved and one thing that you
continually hear around the league is
that Trent Williams what he wants in
terms of contract and what Washington
wants in terms of compensation are just
- hi - get him moved right now yeah and
I feel bad for Tripp Williams I mean
this guy has been trying to get out of
this relationship so hard but it's just
not working for him they want to keep
him around he wants to explore new
things I think it's just time to cut
ties with him if you're the Redskins try
to move him try to get a pic back for
him but it's just not gonna work out
you're not gonna mend that relationship
at the end of his career he probably
wants to go somewhere where he can have
some more success as a team with a
winning team let him do it
find a pic find a partner and all signs
pointed to that they were holding out
for a second-round pick and it felt like
guys at some point last year they might
have even had a chance to get a
first-round pick and Bruce Allen would
not move him so this is really this is
an asset that has just fallen off a
cliff right now when you look at Trent
Williams and like you said Melo for
Trent you kind of almost feel bad for
him because he feels like the
organization at a time was dishonest
with him and that he wants to go out and
and not play there anymore on top of
wanting to get paid and it feels like
there's so many hurdles right now if the
Redskins don't cave soon this thing will
get more and more ugly through certain
voices in the media yeah I think so
you're gonna see both sides come out you
know just like we saw with the CBA
you're gonna see each side come out
supporting their stance so Trent
Williams once moved Cam Newton I see one
of you added this Cam Newton will be
released today by the Carolina Panthers
and we've said all along the suppliers
could be very very difficult to trade
because of the medical situation if
you're a team if you're the Chargers and
you let Cam Newton can't bring him in
for a physical right now you have to
find a neutral party basically an
orthopedist is what a lot of people are
doing to get the physical done so Cam
Newton gonna be released and I think
that he is gonna have a little bit of a
tough time finding a deal unless he's
willing to take a short term contract
that is very incentive Laden because of
the questions by injury a guy who's been
hurt for the last 18 months basically I
mean yeah that's a good like two seasons
that we've been seeing Cam Newton and I
love Cam Newton and I know that we've
been talking a lot about him and even
what he did in college
I love Cam Newton but I I think that
he's another guy kind of like Todd
Gurley he's gonna have to take a short
contract yeah throwing a lot of
incentives for him but I just don't know
if I'm gonna give this guy a two or
three year deal to come be my
quarterback he's another guy
gonna have to take that Ryan Tannehill
deal and go to a team that needs a
backup that maybe he can compete for a
starting job I think Oakland would have
been a really good fit with Jon Gruden
they don't need him now now they have
Marcus Mariota and I think one of the
questions you have to ask with Cam right
now is is he gonna take less money to go
somewhere where he feels like he can
build back up his stock because it's
probably gonna be a one-year deal no
matter where he goes but if New England
calls would you go there they don't have
a lot of cap space guys that don't they
do if they have any interest in Cam
Newton and I'm not sure if they would or
if they do but they're not offering him
twenty million dollars a year or
anything like this would be a very very
low market deal but if your Cam Newton
you're sitting there and going man if I
play for cheap this year if I feel like
I'm healthy and get back to being myself
I could cash in on one of those 60 to
100 million dollar deals the following
year so it's gonna be a very interesting
time for Cam Newton and I'm very curious
to see how the league values him after
everybody really already made their
quarterback plans for next year I think
that's the hard part is it like where
does he go
you know we've said the Chargers but
they're been reports they're not gonna
add a guy until the draft
well the Panthers even gave him
permission to seek a trade so for the
past I don't even know what day it is
anymore for the past week Cam Newton and
his agent have probably been talking to
teams saying hey come get our guy come
get our guy and the Panthers haven't
found any partners for him which is
telling me that no teams willing to give
up a fifth rounder for Cam Newton and
also I mean the Panthers also traded
Kyle Allen for a fifth rounder which is
shocking to the kyln gambit surrounder
players on drafts for agent then you get
a fifth round pick back for him so
they're gonna roll into next year the
Panthers with Teddy Bridgewater will
Grier and PJ Walker
that's the quarterbacks and so I do
think with Cam like we saw the Bears at
Nick Foles
Martin like Melo said we saw the Raiders
had Marcus Mariota where does a player
like Cam Newton even go to where you
feel like you have a chance to get on
the field and try to as you said Connor
try to recoup some of that lost value
there's not an obvious situation unless
you know unless the Dolphins say you
know what we don't like it in one in
this class we're gonna do it for you
come tutor 204 a year and be that guy
maybe the Saints take him on and say hey
stay in the NFC
I'll come work behind Drew Brees who's
often injured Taysom Hill is our tight
end fullback be our backup quarterback
be our teddy bridgewater yeah there's
not not an obvious fit for Cam Newton at
all
Mitchell Kyle Allen got traded that was
a bit of a surprise but now Ron Rivera
has a good backup or maybe competition
for Dwayne Haskins in Washington but
this one surprised me guys I'm trying to
watch tiger king last night sitting on
my deck and Travis Frederick up and
retires 29 years old but injuries have
been an issue for the player who missed
a season not that long ago due to an
issue and the Cowboys that drafted
Connor McGovern in the third round last
year basically with this in mind that
this could happen but Travis Frederick
probably the best center in the NFL at
times over the last eight seasons now
headed off to retirement yeah you hate
to see these guys retire early
especially a guy who is at the top of
his position but if you're a Cowboys fan
I think you're gonna be okay I think
that offensive line is still gonna be
one of the best in the league even
without Travis Frederick there and the
interior offensive line of this draft
class I think you can find somebody late
now they can maybe come in just in case
you don't like what McGovern has given
you yeah I'm not expecting them to use a
first or second round pick on a center
just because of this retirement I mean
there were reports that internally they
were ready for this they have Joe Looney
they have McGovern there I think they
feel good enough about one of those two
guys to hold the fort for this year so
obviously if it's it's a Dallas fan your
Dallas fan this is not what you want to
hear Frederick's a Pro Bowl player a
year after year a really good player but
I don't think this the ship is sinking
because of this retirement no I don't
think it is either I think that this is
a very well-prepared team as Melo and I
were talking before we started recording
today he said men on the I could play
center on that line and they'd probably
be okay because we play between Zack
Martin Connor Williams with Tyrone Smith
and Wow Collins if you're looking for
some silver lining
now you've cleared up his cap space now
you're paying a rookie center instead of
an all-pro center so I was trying to
look up I mean cap space was about 10
million dollars so now you have that
maybe now you can get that dak deal done
and still have one of the best offensive
lines in football all right how about
yeah it would have been nice and moves a
little earlier though for Byron you know
you know you're absolutely right they
see he saw a Marius contract it was like
man I gotta get out of here if they're
paying that dude that much all right how
about this Marcus Mariota speaking of
contracts I know the money that came in
was reported and it's like god it's good
backup money but I saw Monday that if
Marcus Mariota ends up playing like a
starter he's gonna get paid like a
starter so it makes me think we've heard
for a long time that there's gonna be
competition for derrick karr last year a
lot of people thought they could have
surprised and drafted a quarterback at
number four overall they did not but now
Derek Carr has legitimate competition
from a player that his GM and head coach
who used to be in the media publicly
loved both guys loved Marcus Mariota now
they haven't yeah and I think that's
what's gonna make it kind of weird about
Gruden and May out there for a while is
that we know the guys that they liked in
the draft we watched Gruden do the
quarterback room for years Mayock been
on NFL Network I think since that damn
thing started but Marcus Mariota I think
this is a contract that a lot of guys
we're talking about Cam Newton earlier I
think that's what they're gonna have to
do you're gonna have to take that one
year prove a deal and I like the fit
here with Oakland I think that it's
gonna push a guy like Derek Carr who
maybe got a little bit comfortable in
that locker room of being that starter
for so long now you bring in another
veteran that can push him but also fits
really well in that offense and what
they're trying to do yeah and Gruden's
obsession with collecting quarterbacks
it's never gonna go away so this one
shouldn't really surprise anyone it
would be ironic
if what happened to Marcus Mariota last
year with Ryan Tannehill happened this
year with Derek Carr Marcus Mariota that
would be pretty crazy I think Carr had a
good year last year so I'm not expecting
him to get benched for any reason but
this is a good you know good injury
insurance I think having Mariota there
and obviously that would have staff that
is very very high on him and quickly
guys I do want to talk about the NCAA
released their top 25 for some reason
they did it in late March well we know
why but a little early for the NCAA to
the top 25 but what was the first word
that came to your mind when you saw the
rams new logo I just still don't get it
like it leaked obvious why and I thought
that it was just gonna leak like we
talked about maybe they leaked it
and they change it a little bit no it's
just not a good logo I don't like the
cartoon type logos I do like the color
scheme sorry Matt you can sit out of
this conversation but going back to the
blue and the yellow I like it honestly
is that different yeah they were more of
like a golden Navy so I like the color
scheme but the logo still just sucks
yeah that's where they blew it the logos
weird I don't like the logo at all I
think the new RAM is fine I think the
font was fine but I just and the colors
are fine but like you said mellow the
logo is the thing that matters here so
you blow that it's just underwhelming
and it just kind of makes you sit there
and you're like what like what was the
need to do this and how many test phases
did this go through where this somehow
is the final result like to me you have
Nike the NFL and riedel are three huge
companies and this is what you come up
with it looks to me I can't not see it's
LA with Donald Trump's hair on it that's
all I see no it's just that yellow
comb-over it's all I can see no matter
where you stand politically I think we
can all agree that's what this even if
you love the hair right that's what a
lot of good look is not and I have very
little room to speak on hair not a good
look all right how about the NCAA's top
25 guys this route this drops kind of
late Monday night Clemson is number one
no surprise there Trevor Lawrence Travis
etn Justin Ross come back number two
Ohio State Justin fields comes back
Shawn Wade came back that defense is
still gonna be very very good and then
number three Alabama too is gone Judy's
gone rugs is gone but you get back Dylan
Moses you get back Devon to Smith and
Jalen Waddell you get back Alex
Leatherwood and Mack Jones actually
played pretty well in the bowl win over
Michigan number for LSU I don't know
about this one guys Jamar chase and
Derrick Stingley yes they lost
everything they lost their defensive
coordinator they lost their offensive
genius and Joe Brady they lost Joe
burrow their entire offensive line their
running back they're tight in just in
Jefferson their two best linebackers
they've got two good receivers coming
back I like Myles Brennan but to have
them at four this is just rewarding your
national champion saying oh you lost
your quarter
we'll still put you top five like I like
LSU we all said it was our favorite
tailgating spot so please don't take
this as me hating on your Yoshi but you
lost almost everything on that offense
and you lost a shitload on that defense
too I just don't see how a lot of blue
blood programs will reload but I don't
think the LSU is in a spot to reload as
a top five team yeah might take a year
it's what it feels like they've had all
these good recruiting classes coming in
obviously they still have a lot of good
football players there but when you look
at how loaded everyone else stayed it I
mean maybe they'll prove us wrong again
guys who knows but I think right now it
does feel like hey you won the national
title game we're not gonna leave you out
of the top five because that would gonna
seem ridiculous rounding out the top ten
Georgia who will be led by Jamie Newman
that seemed a fun team to watch or again
at number six Justin Herbert's gone but
penny Sewell and cave on the Bedok are
back so they're probably gonna be okay
Oklahoma at seven we're gonna see
mellows best friend Spencer rattler at
quarterback eight Penn State led by
Micah Parsons and Sean Clifford 9
Florida Dan Mullins Gators Cal Trask
finished the year very very well last
year see where he ends up and then at
number 10 all burn a team that if you
pressed me right now to name an Auburn
starter who is returning I don't think I
could do it they have their quarterback
that me and Connor Lowe there we go
favorite player in the country yeah I
mean other than that they had a good
year last year I think nine and four was
probably better than most
Auburn fans thought they would do but
Gus Malzahn kind of has the high
expectations and he fails low
expectations he succeeds so I'm not
expecting a big year for Auburn
especially if they're coming into the
year number ten we have seven or eight
quarterbacks in the 2020 class that
believe could be starters if not rot
rookie year at least at some point early
in their career and we're gonna do our
best fits for these guys dream fits not
where we think they'll go and some of
these are gonna be the teams that don't
even need a quarterback right now so
please please please remember these are
not predictions it's where we if we
could pick this is where the
quarterbacks would go so they can have
the best chance to succeed in the NFL
it's like if they were free agents
where's the best landing spot obviously
they're not free agents and like you
said we have seven or eight guys here
not going to get into the
eight Stanley's of the world but just
the top end guys no I do love me some
Nate Stanley on day three but not
starting there all right how about this
one guys let's go with joey borrow mr.
Heisman Trophy sixty touchdowns this
year one of the best college football
seasons we have ever seen for a
quarterback he will be the number one
pick going to the Cincinnati Bengals
none of us believe that is the best fit
if I could pick anywhere for Joe burrow
it would be the New Orleans Saints I
know y'all are gonna talk about Oh Joe
Brady Joe Brady was running Sean
Payton's office this is not Joe Brady's
offense maybe he tinkered with it a
little bit but if you could put Joe
burrow in that often so Michael Thomas
Manuel Sanders Alvin Kamara that
offensive line and Sean Payton yeah I'm
taking that all day yeah and let me tell
you why you're wrong with the Saints oh
it's because Joe burrows 24 years old
he's ready to play right now and he's
ready to win right now that means the
New England Patriots are the best
landing spot for Joe borough they are in
a desperate need for a quarterback some
would say not me but I think that going
here gives Belichick the opportunity to
keep on winning and I'm telling you guys
I think Joe burrow plays just like Tom
Brady not predicting six wins not
predicting the best quarterback ever but
the play style there is very similar
guys that can move around to the pocket
can find those open receivers keeps his
eyes downfield I think the New England
Patriots are the best landing spot for
Joe burrow mellow cutting the throat of
his boy Terrance didn't write just hate
to see the hat and I'll do the same I'll
cut Matt's boys Teddy here I'm going
with the Panthers listen I mean this is
just reuniting him with Joe Brady that's
the thought process behind this one Joe
Brady listen I'm not gonna say he
created his offense for Joe borough but
I think all of borough's traits and
strains X we're executing that offense
flawlessly with Joe Brady and they have
some good players there DJ Moore had a
quietly very very productive year
Christian McCaffrey is the undisputed
best running back in football right now
so I think for borough it would have
been really exciting if he went to
Carolina a new ownership new head coach
a lot of energy down there not gonna
happen but I thought it would have been
at least a really really good scheme fit
in landing spot all right how about to
talk about Aloha coming out of Alabama I
think that natural I wanted to say the
Saints but I'm not going to give
every quarterback to the Saints cuz
that's not fair so I went with the
second best option in my opinion for two
and that is the Los Angeles chargers not
only from a business perspective which
is amazing you get a guy from Hawaii who
now plays in LA he can be the face of
the Chargers as they move into a new
stadium and now have the best logo in
Southern California which is very
important to it and those powder blues
those white you knees would look so
clean but also you have mike williams
keenan allen austin Eckler hunter henry
and an offensive line that now has Trey
Turner
I think the scheme fit for two would be
perfect to the point that I actually
hope the Chargers trade up and make this
happen because tua with the Chargers is
magical it's perfect yeah I like that
fit too but I haven't used the Saints
yet on my board and I am gonna use them
I think the fit is just too perfect I
have him comp to Drew Brees I think that
a lot of questions with tua is the
health let him sit from two years behind
drew Brees let him learn the offense a
little bit and when he's comfortable he
is the quarterback in waiting that's
what I went with as well I think it's
such an obvious fit he does have the
play style like Brees he does fit in
that offense with pinpoint accuracy
Michael Thomas Emmanuel Sanders they'll
catch 100 balls each probably more than
that Alvin Camaro who's a good pass
catcher as well I think when you look at
- just the pocket movements the pocket
feel and that intermediate and
intermediate accuracy which is nearly
flawless at times he really would he'd
be there next year Brees it's that
simple to me it is a fantastic fit for
him it's just in that offense the way it
works just in a Herbert coming out of
Oregon the top senior quarterback in
this year it's got a second not the top
senior it was tough Senior Bowl
quarterback sorry Jill Varro top senior
Bowl quarterback we saw I'm actually
gonna give Justin Herbert to the New
England Patriots when you look at what
Tom Brady was able to do playing from
the pocket executing those throws
underneath
I think the Herbert does a lot of those
things but he's more mobile than Tom
Brady so you still have a big six-foot
six 240 pound quarterback who could play
from the pocket but also somebody who
now gives you a little bit of mobility
getting to the outside of course I would
have burrow into it for the Patriots but
getting down the list
I think Herbert is the next best option
if you're gonna keep josh mcdaniels
offense now Herbert does have to get
better
working to second and third progression
I think that's the biggest hole in his
game right now I don't know if there's
anyone better in the league to teach you
that than Josh McDaniels yeah and I
think maybe we should have touched on
this at the top I only picked one team
for quarterback I already use the Saints
for to us so I'm not gonna use the
McKinney to sew with Herbert I'm looking
at quarterback needy teams and I haven't
go into the Colts I think that's a great
fit to sit behind Phillip Rivers for a
year maybe two whatever it is learn that
offense and again come in I think he's a
guy that probably needs to sit and learn
in offense yeah I think there are two
quarterbacks you know maybe only jobber
oh that's really ready to start on day
one in this draft class the rest of
these guys probably gonna have to sit I
like to fit with the offense and what
they want to do downfield and they
really need a quarterback going forward
not a lot of guys on roster in 2021
offensive lines would be great for him
mm-hmm
and I went with the Chargers for Herbert
which is a very very likely scenario I
really think the Chargers come out of
this thing with one of two or Herbert
when all is said and done and there's a
couple reasons but the main one I think
for me guys is environment I think
Herbert is somebody that needs the right
environment to succeed and I think the
Colts are a really good example because
you can sit there for a year you're
working with the staff that'll be very
hands-on with you it'll be you know
eased into the situation I think it's
the same with the Chargers they like
what they have in Tyrod Taylor they're
they really do where Herbert does not
have to play right away I think Anthony
Lin is an underrated coach I think they
have a lot of pieces on offense that
make things easier on the quarterback
whether it's Austin Eckler quietly one
of the best pass catching backs in
football we know how good Keenan Allen
is hunter Henry there's so many pieces
there that and they even added to the
offensive line this offseason where for
Herbert the environment and the offense
around him is the best chance to develop
and you keep him on the west coast a guy
who's really never been outside of
Eugene Oregon yeah he did not want to
leave I mean I mean even stayed in
school to play with his brother for an
extra year so I think it's safe to say
he's you know he likes where he is he
doesn't need that kind of change where
you're going across the country that
should've been an option for me in high
school stay a next year to play with you
should have right man to the next would
have been fun probably to play college
ball that way all right Jordan will love
coming out of Utah State
of a small school guy gigantic arm very
good mobility you're gonna hear
comparisons even if they're lazy to a
poor man's Patrick mahomes when I look
at the Cincinnati Bengals guys I see a
team and Zach Taylor they have weapons
on the outside with Tyler Boyd AJ Green
you have a great back in Joe Mixon you
need someone to give you a bit of a
spark so of the quarterbacks who are
available still I think Jordan love to
the Bengals would be the best fit also
he gets to go somewhere there's going to
be no pressure on Jordan love to be
great right out of the gate because
Cincinnati they have not been a good
team
Andy Dalton they're so ready to move on
from this kind of boring passer who's
just efficient and he checks the ball
down a ton if you introduce a big play
threat whether it be through his arms or
legs like Jordan love is Cincinnati
these fans are gonna they think skyline
Chile's good imagine how good they're
gonna think Jordan love is when they see
somebody who can actually throw the ball
down the field and that's why I'm gonna
put Jordan love to the Chargers I like
Connor was saying earlier with her brain
that those receivers are very good they
bailed out Phillip Rivers on a lot of
5050 balls over the last season
Austin Eckler can be a great check down
for a guy like Jordan love the offensive
lines not real good
but he's mobile enough like you said a
poor man's Pat mahomes and also I'm
putting him to the Chargers because this
guy throws a lot of interceptions and as
a Chiefs fan I like that I had to be
speechless for a second all right Jordan
fluff I'm going with the Steelers once
again get that vertical game going I
think they like that with their
quarterbacks they have drafted some guys
that can move a little bit before so I
think what love you know I'm not gonna
call them big been a different body type
but they've they're both guys that can
simply get outside the pocket and push
the ball down the field and we believe
Big Ben's coming back Jordan Lowe is
somebody that needs to sit this year he
has to sit this year I would be really
shocked to see if he doesn't get them a
home's treatment guys we're the team
that takes him is just very open that
they are completely okay with
essentially NFL red shirting him
barring significant injury and I think
Pittsburgh is a really exciting landing
spot and in regards to that
speaking of Pittsburgh that is where I
have our good friend Jacob Eason from
the University of Washington go
big armed quarterback who has to win
from the pocket probably the least
mobile of the the top seven quarterbacks
so we're gonna talk about today so he
needs that system that foundation of
play from the pocket win from between
the tackles he can do that Eason
struggled against the best defenses that
he faced
he's gonna need coached up let him sit
behind big bin for a year and then I
really believe like the the trade off
from Ben's arm to Ethan's arm is not
that different you have juju James
Washington John Drake Johnson they have
some big weapons at wide receiver need a
little bit of help in the backfield but
I think if we're just talking about
where could ease and go to be developed
and then have success Pittsburgh is that
spot yeah and I'm gonna agree with you
on this one too and I saw on Twitter
earlier today somebody was tweeting at
its top machi and a quarterback to the
Steelers what's like I'm sorry guys
you're going to need a quarterback going
forward I don't think the big Big Ben
has three years left in him at the
quarterback position and I like Jacob
Eason here I think he's very similar to
Ben Roethlisberger with the big arm a
little bit of mobility I think he's more
athletic then he gets credit for for
both these guys Big Ben and Jacob Eason
so I think the fit here with the
Steelers just made too much sense for
Eason I went with the Bucks now this one
is not realistic at all because I think
when you sign Tom Brady for two years
they got to be drafting for win now or
at least you we would think that that's
what Tom wants Bruce Arians I don't know
how many years he has left coaching so I
think he'll be pushing the GM to do the
same thing but in terms of scheme fit
and with the coach I love Eason in the
Bucks offense and Bruce Arians
traditional offense that Carson Palmer
you know kind of stands still in the
pocket
although Eason has this horrible habit
of rolling out the wrong way guys you
know turns his back to the line
it's how he gets himself in trouble over
and over again but if you can teach him
to be a true pocket passer pushing the
ball down the field I would love to see
what it gets you a Bruce Arians no risk
it no biscuit aryans to be great for
Jacob Eason right Jake from from Georgia
a little bit of a small guy doesn't have
great athleticism or the biggest arm
sounds to me a lot like Kirk Cousins
we've seen someone like that fit very
well in the Minnesota offense with Gary
Kubiak with kevin Stefanski
so I'm just gonna give Jake from to the
Minnesota Vikings
no they just signed Kirk Cousins for
three years so not ideal from that
perspective but I honestly believe that
from tops out I say could back up and
maybe spot starter so the best chance
for him to have in an NFL success would
be an offense like this that is familiar
with that type of passer yeah and I'm
gonna go with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers I
think he's a lot like Tom Brady he's got
a good football IQ when you look at Jake
from but also needs to sit then if you
can sit behind Tom Brady for the next
three years not an ideal fit in a Bruce
Arians offense but neither was Tom Brady
so I think that the ideal fit for him
come in sit learn behind the best
quarterback that's ever played the
position and then maybe put yourself in
a spot to take over to be that cute
about quarterback of the future and I
put from with a Brady's old team the New
England Patriots all we hear about from
is the high IQ you know future coach
kind of person Belichick loves drafting
these guys he's drafted three
quarterbacks that are already NFL
coaches today right now Kliff Kingsbury
head coach of the Cardinals Kevin
O'Connell the offensive coordinator with
the Rams and Zach Robinson the assistant
quarterback coach or the RAM so
Belichick he loves drafting these high
IQ players that are projected as
long-term backups that's what I have
Fromm projected at right now but who
knows maybe Belichick can get starting
reps out of him O'Connor you might be
too young to remember this but they also
brought in major Applewhite for a tryout
out of Texas and he's a coach at the
college level now so there's one more
there you go or maybe men even more just
don't keep up with major Applewhite in
the roster movie sorry I do okay I this
is why I still you know after hanging
out and work there after hanging out a
major in mobile we do need to just not
tell them that they're each coming on
the pod be like hey Chris you know come
on stick to football and let's get them
it was get a zoom meeting the by you
know it would be amazing it would be a
celebrity deathmatch right I would yeah
it would be great alright jaylen Hertz
is the last one this is something I
actually was doing a mock drafts until
the Chicago Bears picked up Nick Foles
but I still love the idea of Jalen Hertz
in Matt Nagi's offense I think some of
the limitations we've seen from Mitchell
true Biscay
ability to get outside the pocket even
though he's a pretty good athlete it's
just he almost seems timid and afraid to
get outside of the pocket and make plays
we know jailer Hertz will do that he
rushed for over 1,000 yards to Oklahoma
this past season go back to his time at
Alabama watch this man make plays with
his feet
I'd be like Matt naggy he almost needs
like someone to recharge him so I'm
gonna light a fire under his ass when
you see the ability of Jalen hurts as a
runner and a thrower
your imaginations gonna go into
overdrive that creativity that we saw in
Kansas City is gonna come back and you
maybe finally get the best out of the
weapons they have there in Chicago yeah
and with Jalen Hertz and again only
trying to use one team one time I'm
running out of options here I didn't
want to take the Bears either because I
didn't want to agree with you again but
they have some quarterbacks in place
there so I went with the Carolina
Panthers
Teddy Bridgewater is getting paid a lot
of money there but it's a short-term
deal I think if you're Jalen Hertz this
could be a Russell Wilson situation go
in there prove what you can do and you
know if Teddy Bridgewater gets hurt
again you're right there to swoop in and
take this job and probably not lose it
again for Hertz I went with the biking
this is a legendary offensive
coordinator there Gary Kubiak you know I
mean he's worked with a lot of different
quarterbacks over the years some mobile
not so you know not some not so much but
when you look at Kubiak there you know I
think back to the days when the Bronco
is actually we were running an efficient
offense with jake the snake' plumber on
those 8,000,000 legs hurts can really
flourish on that bootleg kind of offense
and Hertz is a better runner even than
jake the snake' was but the way they can
move outside of the pocket the way they
can cut the field in half and really
pick apart in the intermediate accuracy
I think Kubiak is the guy now Kirk
Cousins is gonna be there for a while
but you still need a long-term backup
and I think for Hertz he's somebody that
would develop really really nicely going
from Lincoln Riley to Gary Kubiak
all right let's do it let's take a break
we come back our player spotlights and
then some draft on draft something we're
trying to do every week now until the
NFL Draft in which to be April 23rd we
don't know yet how it's gonna be but we
know when it's gonna be so we will let
you know when we know but guarantee we
will be covering it in some form or
fashion so player spotlights we get into
our scouting notes guys I'll kick it off
Joe Reid from Virginia known best as a
kick returner I believe five kickoff
touchdowns in his career 33 yards per
kick average in 2019 this man is amazing
when he's back deep he has that perfect
body type six foot tall 215 pounds
almost built like a running back with
big lower body he's got good musculature
throughout his entire frame so he can
bounce off tacklers but he also has that
squat stocky type that shows burst and
you really see it in the open field as
he kick returner but then also working
underneath now Joe Reed played almost
exclusively in the slot he did at times
play in the backfield or in a Flex
position for the Cavaliers you watched
him sneak out of the backfield catch
balls get upfield you watched him sneak
into the red zone
he's not the greatest route runner which
is why I think he's gonna be a date 3
pick but the potential is here if you
put Joe Reed with the creative offensive
mind not only is he gonna be a very good
return man but someone who can help your
offense on jet sweeps pop passes bubble
screens working on short underneath
routes and then having the ability to
turn that into a chunk play with big
yards after catch potential so I'm a Joe
Reed fan I think he's probably a 5th or
6th round pick but there is big
potential here for him to be a playmaker
in the NFL yeah I love that Matt and you
know what else I love I love hearing you
get very excited about talking about
another man's body really I'm sitting
here listening to you talk about muscles
and everything this guy is loaded I love
him because I didn't know much about him
before so thank you for that update
I'm gonna go with a safety prospect that
I've done some work on I really like
Geno Smith Geno Smith the quarterback
yeah Chino's take a punch Geno's stone
out of Iowa he's another one of those
Iowa guys is like Matt Bowen over there
he's short right that's one of the
biggest knocks on this guy's he's not
very big but I like him is what I'm
calling I guess swing safety he does at
all he can play strong he can play free
he played nickel corner whatever you
want this guy to do he's gonna do it
the only Knox I have on him again link
short handy ran that for 640 that's not
good but we're talking about a late
round guy here probably around for
around 5 I'm not talking to top 5 safety
maybe a top 10 safety in this draft but
also a guy that's gonna come in work his
ass off play hard and probably give you
some good reps on special teams as well
and my player spotlights gonna be on
Darnay homes the corner from UCLA I
think if he was 6:1 with good lanes we'd
be talking about him as a top 60 top 50
pick but he's a shorter corner guys you
know 510 195 good speed highly
competitive a really really good
aggressive tackler but I think most
importantly he's fluid in coverage he's
smoothing coverage he turns his head to
find the ball he's very very you know
high character player it just lives in
the film room kind of player I think
when you look at Darnay Holmes he's
somebody that will succeed at the next
level even if he has to play in the slot
because of size restrictions and those
slot corners one of the toughest tasks
for any kind of defense when you're
isolated in the slot you have to be a
good tackler because of all those
underneath routes all those bubble
screens and I think Holmes is a guy that
will come in and and develop into a an
upper echelon slot cornerback in the NFL
even if he is a fourth or fifth round
pick I I remember Darnay Holmes from the
Senior Bowl you talk about him as a slot
corner I'll tell you one thing I loved
about him as he was matched up against
one of those big receivers Colin Johnson
or Michael Pittman jr. I don't remember
which one but he was so feisty that me
and Big Country were like look at this
matchup it looks like a little brother
just out there picking at the big
brother just Nagatani pansy trying to
get the ball I really liked what I saw
from Darnay Holmes at the Senior Bowl
and I like you said Connor nothing he's
quickness shows up absolutely shows up
and I do love Geno stone I think he is
the type of guy one thing about team
building I try to write about this a lot
in scouting reports if we're talking
about a fourth or fifth receiver or a
third or four safety you have to play
special teams like that's a big part of
your job so like you just said Colin
Johnson I worry about Colin Johnson he's
six foot six 250
pounds can't run he's not playing
specialty yes he got a gunner he's gonna
be lumped in with guys like chase
Claypool who cut her teeth in college
football playing special teams being a
gunner and doing everything else so I
think you're right and you know when our
draft 400 stuff starts to come out as
players get drafted a lot of it is gonna
be
can you play special teams when we get
you know past the third round you have
to be able to play special teams all
right take a break come back it's draft
on draft on